aujourd'hui un petit tutoriel pour vous
présenter la structure radio
concentriques des métropoles européennes
dans le cadre de notre étude des grandes
métropoles
alors pour étayer cet exposé je me base
sur deux sources dont voici les
références avec notamment le manuel de
géographie 3e 6e
alors aujourd'hui le plan l'exposé les
métropoles d'europe et leur structure
radio concentré qu'on verra après de
quoi il s'agit avec différentes unités
territoriales unités l'espace qui vont
nous être utile pour l'analyse d'abord
un noyau urbain qui va être vraiment le
centre vide ensuite une première
couronne constitué de faubourg et de
quartiers bourgeois du 19e siècle c'est
ce qu'on va considérer comme la proche
banlieue
donc là on est déjà dans la banlieue
mais la banlieue plus proche par
opposition avec la grande banlieue est
plus éloignée est plus vaste que la
proche banlieue et enfin un dernier
unité qui est l'espace périurbain pv
autour urbain la ville autour de la
ville c'est vraiment l'espace le plus ou
moins éloignées et le plus vaste qui tua
extérieur vraiment très très loin du
centre de la ville alors tout d'abord un
plan radio concentriques et bien je me
baserai sur la démission qui est dans
vos feuilles l'espace métropolitain est
ainsi composé d'une série de couronnes
on peut les voir ici qui se succèdent du
centre à la périphérie
donc on a différents tableaux ici ces
anneaux on les voit très très bien on a
ce centre puis si une deuxième couronne
et une troisième couronne ou un
troisième à de l'oif là c'est un modèle
concentric et la wii devient radio
concentriques
c'est parce que vous voyez ici entre le
centre et certains éléments certaines
couronne on des rayons qui partent vers
l'extérieur du centre parfois de la
banlieue mais on a un système comme ça
d'une dimension à la fois concentriques
mais aussi radio concentriques avec ses
rayons perpendiculaire ils permettent
d'avoir des axes de pénétration ou
d'évacuation de la ville donc on a ces
différentes voies de circulation radial
1 qui converse qui convergent vers le
centre ou inversement à l'extérieur ces
différentes
radiall sont reliées entre elles par des
voies de circulation circulaire sont
bien ces anneaux généralement dans les
limites sont les boulevards de ceinture
le périphérique 1 qui prennent
généralement place aux limites des
différentes communes urbaines
voilà ce qu'est un plomb radio
concentriques alors bien sûr ici c'est
un modèle théorique donc c'est à dire
que c'est un dessin qui simplifiait qui
tend à rendre compte de toutes les
villes européennes dans beaucoup de
villes européennes on va se rendre
compte qu'un peu de choses près on a
cette structure qui revient évidemment
ça va pas être exactement la même et ça
ne va pas être symétrique est on comment
dire vraiment parfaitement généfique
comme celle ci on va voir des formes
plus ou moins circulaire mais on peut
tout mais ramené d'une manière
simplifiée à ce modèle alors je pars du
centre ici tout d'abord ya un noyau
urbain c'est toujours la base aux
ménages voient plus en avant on à
l'apparition d'une ville par rapport à
un site généralement un site qui est
bien défendable ou qui est située près
de facilités de communication par
exemple comme les voies navigables
c'est souvent le cas donc on à
l'apparition de ce centre est à partir
de ce centre on va bien sûr avoir des
axes des changes qui vont partir dans
différentes élections lors c'est pas
forcément des lignes droites
évidemment son dire elle différente
artères comme ça qu'ils vont permettre
un échange le commerce de marchandises
de biens mais aussi bien sur les
migrations et les déplacements de
personnes
alors ce centre évidemment va être
entouré au moyen-âge d'une enceinte d'un
mur fortifié ou de plusieurs plusieurs
murs et ses murs on perd ses deux portes
par par lesquels passent ces différents
axes de circulation ces différentes
artères au 19e siècle
évidemment les invasions et les
populations autre chose à faire que de
te faire la guerre
donc on n'a plus d'utilité de ses
anciens remparts qu'on va abattre dans
la plupart des cadres la plupart des
villes pour permettre vraiment à la
ville de partir à la conquête de
l'espace extérieur davantage extra muros
qui va permettre le développement de la
ville et par une perforation comme ça de
ses anciennes murailles et donc on à la
constitution de la banlieue proche
on va d'abord appelé les faubourgs alors
il faut bourrer une image par exemple de
ce qu'est un faubourg photo pardon il
faudra fille de ski info bout on va
retrouver quand même des petites rues
comme dans le centre historique un des
petites rues sinueuses et étroites mais
on va avoir de plus en plus tendance
plus on va vers l'extérieur a retrouvé
des grands axes des points de fuite
comme ça qui permettent de rejoindre
l'extérieur de la ville l'extérieur ce
tram muros voilà les faubourgs et la
première couronne de la banlieue
et bien sûr là on va retrouver ses
murailles cette enceinte qui veut qu'ils
vont être qui va être remplacé par des
axes de circulation généralement par des
boulevards on voit bien ici les
boulevards alors si vous prenez la
majorité des villes en europe cinq sur
les grandes métropoles des petites
villes comme à tout comme mons même
comme tournée vous celle évidemment vous
allez trouver à l'emplacement des
anciens remparts si on prend des
anciennes cartes et qu'on enlève leur
ont pas on va retrouver à cet
emplacement là exactement les boulevards
qui font le tour de la ville et autour
de ces boulevards on va trouver des
maisons quand même assez luxueuse qui
ont été construites à la fin du 19e
siècle début du 20e siècle où on avait
toutes les populations les plus
bourgeoise qui s'était bien enrichi à
l'époque l'industrie est florissante et
toutes ces populations vont venir
s'installer sur ces boulevards ils sont
vraiment des points de vue c'est aussi à
16 ans voilà qu'on va retrouver les
différentes gares puisque le chemin de
fer c'est au 19e siècle qu'il apparaît
donc c'est pour ça que dans les villes
on va retrouver plus ou moins les
guerres à égale distance du centre
c'est pour cette raison et bien sûr une
fois que ces remparts sont tombés la
ville va continuer à grandir et à
constituer cette banlieue proche avec un
habitat qui est quand même relativement
dense un des maisons sont quand même
encore collées les unes aux autres et il
ya beaucoup de personnes qui résident à
cet endroit la densité de population
sont toujours assez importante
ensuite on va voir la ville qui va
continue à se développer comme ça vers
l'extérieur et on va voir apparaître
différents axes routiers et si
symboliser en rouge parce qu'ici on est
sur des densités de populations qui sont
moins importants donc c'est plus facile
de tracer les déroutes et on l'a on est
au début du 20e siècle milieu du 21e
siècle
juste après la guerre on va commencer à
avoir chacun une automobile dans chacun
des meilleurs
chaque ménage razon sa voiture et donc
on va voir vraiment une expansion des
routes et autoroutes hier est donc là on
va créer généralement des grands
périphériques des grandes couronnes
autoroutière autour des villes avec
différents axes évidemment qu'ils vont
relier les autres grandes villes près de
ces axes on va retrouver évidemment de
grandes entreprises qui vont venir
s'installer de grandes industries et qui
vont former vraiment des quartiers
industriels qui vont eux mêmes après
attirer des travailleurs qui vont
s'installer près de ses quartiers près
de ses usines
nous on a la dent cette grande banlieue
différents types d'activités à des gens
qui viennent pour dormir pour habiter
évidemment et d'autres pour travailler
c'est ce qu'ont vraiment vague banlieue
alors après dans certaines régions on va
voir l'apparition de grands immeubles
comme ça des immeubles tout ou des
pavillons qui vont être construits dans
sept pays
ferry dans cette zone comme ça cette
nouvelle zone créée à partir de la fin
de la seconde guerre mondiale on aura
aussi des villas quatre façades qui vont
fleurir un style comme le style de
pavillons que vous voyez là en images
avec faut bien se dire la nécessité
quasi d'avoir une voiture parce que là
où vous êtes vraiment un exter de la
ville il ya très peu de commerces donc
si vous voulez vraiment faire beaucoup
c'est tout ça tout le monde ne peut pas
être desservis par les transports en
commun donc là il faut avoir une voiture
dont vous voyez que l'émergence de ces
ce nouveau territoire est vraiment lié à
l'avènement de l'automobile au fait que
l'automobile deviennent vraiment quelque
chose de très courant avant les années
60 les automobiles étaient calmes cannes
chose de relativement rares à partir 60
chaque ménage possède son automobile
donc tout est lié et donc je vais on va
voir
le développement de cet espace
périurbain vraiment sur des espaces très
très grand et on va avoir des petites
villes avant qu'ils étaient je veux dire
à la périphérie des grandes métropoles
et des plus grandes villes qui vont être
vraiment absorber des petits villages
qui vont vraiment être absorbé par cette
expansion périurbain cette expansion
périodes alors on a le cas bruxelles à
bruxelles si vous sortez du ring et
notamment du côté de l art to over reis
vous allez avoir vraiment d'anciens
villages qui on est vraiment été
rattrapé par la ville et qui maintenant
font partie de la ville donc ça donne un
espace assez hétéroclite assez différent
n'est pas très homogène
voilà et bien sûr dans cet espace
périurbain il va y avoir des
lotissements qui vont être faits avec
des nouveaux habitants qui vont venir y
résider à toute la difficulté évidemment
c'est que on est de plus en plus loin du
centre ville
donc si vous travaillez dans le
centre-ville ou si vous voulez vous
rendre dans le centre ville ça devient
très difficile est pour ça qu un saint
amand levin sont tellement grandes que
les centres-villes dépérissent parce que
les personnes n'ont plus le temps le
signal est évidemment donc voilà cet
espace périurbain on va voir aussi
naître des décès huit en boxe on appelle
ça les centres commerciaux comme ça
qu'ils naissent à l'extérieur des villes
avec ce pari plein dedans c'est new que
ça soit je prends une panne d'eau ddd
tomenko et tout ce qui s'ensuit décret
fait le jeu ne s'est pas de media markt
puisque vous voulez comme ont commencé
un petit peuvent qui peuvent exister
s'installe à ce moment là vraiment
d'onde dans des des zonings commerciaux
de ce type là dans cet espace périurbain
et ici vous pouvez voir sur cette
photographie aérienne que l'espace
périurbain finalement vas etre trés
diversifié on va avoir des zones
commerciales des zones commerciaux on
vient de le dire mais encore des
entreprises des enfants des villages qui
se sont fait englobé par la ville de
nouveaux habitats sous forme de
lotissements et encore des zones où
pratique l'agriculture donc là on a
vraiment un espace qui est très
difficile à comprendre parce qu'il est
très très diversifié voilà ici l'exposé
avec un petit récapitulatif s'il ya
vraiment que deux choses à retenir
retenait d'abord le plan radio
concentriques de quoi s'agit-il
c'est vraiment ce schéma qui a été
montré tout à l'heure où le début d'
exposer que vous retrouvez dans vos
feuilles 1-1 structure en cercles reliés
par des rayons et les trois grandes
unités dé ce parce qu'on va utiliser
pour analyser la ville à la fois le
centre la banlieue va prendre les
proches et la banlieue
la grande banlieue et l'espace
périurbain
bien sûr le reste est aussi à revenir à
savoir de quoi il s'agit mais ça c'est
vraiment les choses à ne pas rater
absolument ben je suis à votre
disposition si vous avez des questions
au prochain coup n'hésitez pas à revoir
une plusieurs fois s'appuyer aussi vous
n'avez pas tout compris
bon travail et bonne fin de journée à
bientôt